[Music]
hi hi hi
I'm Louise I'm the interaction designer
on the WNYC data news team this is my
first ignite talk so I'm gonna spend the
next few minutes navigating us through
some of the things we know about the
color red to provide us some context I
grew up in a creepy no California which
is home to Apple headquarters where
everyone's parents knew programming and
I would spend summers in Taiwan where
everyone was totally superstitious so
red red in the American flag represents
hardiness and valor and the bloodshed
that was that happened for the
independence of the 13 colonies and red
for the Tonys flag stands for the red
soil under the brilliant Sun red is all
over
Tony's and Chinese households the Red
Door is important it beckons in good
fortune and happiness in Chinese lore
the red thread represents your face it's
represents love and kind of a faded way
the red thread connects you with your
beloved
it'll tingle it'll stretch but we'll
never be cut in ancient Hindu and
Tibetan fought the red chakra which is
the root chakra is the basis for your
will to survive and to want to live and
to reproduce it sends up energy to to
let you think and relate to others read
in Western in the Western world here you
know it's Valentine's Day red represents
love and like a sweeter way you that's
where we really start to see red you
know take on this literal way because
the heart is red red lipstick very much
in fashion this year it's kind of a
two-way signal you know like you're
you're projecting that you have
confidence and power and at the same
time you're wanting the attention like
the red doors in our representation of
circulatory system
represents the blood that's oxygen-rich
that's sending nutrients and we'll
sending oxygen to your body oxygen is
what is what our body needs and blood is
red because blood has hemoglobins which
binds to iron molecules which bind to
oxygen molecules which planet which
replenishes our body so iron also is
very important to us too in other ways
here's an iron sickle from the Iron Age
in ancient Greece iron melts at a higher
point than bronze which is the Bronze
Age was just before the Iron Age and it
was around the time that we started to
develop the written alphabet and
language iron all over Mars iron is in
the iron dust that spread over Mars but
what actually makes it red is the iron
on Mars is already oxidized this is kind
of a tangent the God of War Mars stands
for war and virility and savagery but
people actually worshipped him to keep
rust off of their iron tools and to keep
wheat fungus off of their crops
here's hell in one of my favorite shows
Ugly Americans it actually has a subway
system yeah I find it so interesting
that read in Western in the Western
world has this kind of like no you know
like do not do this and I think I think
it's interesting that maybe that's why
we chose red for a stop sign because
it's so urgent you know it's a lot more
its lot it's louder than yellow for
instance it has this you know has this
idea don't do the thing that's in this
sign or or there will be consequences
and I think that's why we choose to use
red in interactions online like this you
know like it tells you hey this needs
your attention it's it's not we wouldn't
really use blue we wouldn't really use
other colors it's always red so what I
want to end with is I know that this has
been kind of schizophrenic what I want
to end with is the boy which is this
kind of wooden Halfmoon thing that you
use in Chinese temples and Tony's
temples to ask the gods questions when
both flat sides are up it means no
when there's a flat side and a round
side up together it means yes but
there's a third possibility which I love
which is that the God is laughing and I
love this because it's I think it's
awesome because it tells you to pause
and reflect and think about the
possibility outside of yes or no we've
seen red take on all of these different
meanings in a day we see like shades of
red with contradictory meanings and
they're all valid and they're all kind
of powerful we don't really think about
it the only difference among all of them
is the context thank you
[Applause]